okay this is daddy's little monster and
he's being an ass cuz he's not telling
me whether this is a to be continued or
not I'm kind of hoping it is because it
ended so quickly and it kind of okay
we're gonna go back to the beginning
here oh wait we see we get a lot of the
answers where you're looking for we
don't Ananas I said I was at the Nana's
whole time joke's on me in the
nightosphere I have a piece of
oh it's called the stuff the stuff I
have a piece of stuff actually sown in
the comment section as you might have a
very goodness comment they wondered how
the demons would feel about the banana
guards bananas are just naturally the
word is funny it's a funny-looking fruit
it's always gonna have a place in comedy
yeah you know it's one it's like it'll
never get old
so anything have you do with a banana
for some reason I just always think is
funny it's just a funny word to me so I
thought that was great I thought that
was a great joke it's a good I like the
way they show it to you know the guy
oh my stomach and it comes out of his
ears so but the way it comes out of his
ear is it's like you know what it is and
the way they treat it so it's it was
pretty cleverly done without saying what
it is you know stuff then actually going
back to what the guy with the books like
this reaction all the more interesting
like wait I mean he's a de bunda shizer
whatever Banesto demon shows the video
there you go
we just will actually watch the South
Park movie last night remember the
German choice video surprisingly no but
you did just see it and that seems to be
a continuing theme of what we just saw
somehow ties back into well actually
considering you just said it shines a
video as Oz we don't in any way talk
about what we chose
saw the Avenger time video what we're
good in these adventure tiny logs
okay so you got Marceline they watch
this video they know now what what
happened Marceline's dad Hudson should
tricked her into putting on this
necklace to take over the business to
him into this great big demon monster
just torturing these people the most
creative ways don't ask
Boba's head is a bunch of so Jake and
and Finn and try to go in and they try
to get the necklace off of her which now
makes sense now I see what they're
talking about the whole saver thing and
they do then they come across the father
who says yeah I just want her to follow
my footsteps and and everything and so
they get the necklace offer if Finn puts
it on himself turns to this great big
demon gets Jake and Marceline out of
there and eventually the father comes
takes the necklace off hand throws Finn
back there Marceline and dad kind of
argue and then like he says Finn and
Jake are okay and she closes the door
it's like wow that's weird
he likes you huh I don't think we should
be friends anymore and it just stops and
then fitness kinda like paralyzed too
because he had the necklace odd and
obviously I guess cuz he's more than he
can't handle it as well the
after-effects
oh my god that'd be awesome if we just
have all episode that kid to the
after-effects of him wearing that many
awesome you do like seeing people
suffering ocean well I don't know I like
seeing it from like that world you know
cuz I love to know the after-effects of
having that on you know cuz it'd be so
strange and I love the logic of that
world I just think it'd be hilarious
so but we'll we'll see if they do
anything for a third episode or if they
just cut it there I don't think Oh cuz
it's like I like personally I don't want
through them just throw the friendship
out or whatever I mean I know they're
not going to get rid of her you know
obviously pretty sure just like a
thousand years old she didn't walk it to
the Sun or anything sometime likely she
sounds like a pretty popular character
that Debbie Lynn
be like the most mean like fu to the
fans that was our exit everybody that
was really correct so that seems
unlikely but but anything's possible
hey if she was gonna have an exit to be
a bigger exit than that I would think um
but or just you want I don't know I
couldn't see them doing that for all the
for all the effort they give to like
like even tree trunks like they didn't
and in that one episode they didn't kill
her off that way like they brought her
but I mean that that's what I'm saying
though like they don't even I love that
gasp how dare you they don't even come
off the fan character so they kill off
the good ones yeah pretty much
um so it's the same it's bad well no I
thought you meant like villain is which
they didn't anyway but I guess they do
kill off like a lot of the villainous
characters explode there with glob now
yes so so okay so I mean but this was
still fun you get a little bit more of
how this world kind of works a few
things are explained like I said but the
whole banana thing what happened with
them um I really liked that guard by the
way I just like whatever voice they got
for that guy just like yeah sorry got
three with the stuff whatever I just
love how he clearly doesn't care anis I
thought the boy second day was pretty
fun I love the design when Finn puts on
the necklace I thought that was a really
cool design I liked that it wasn't just
the exact same just a different light
color I mean I guess Marceline looked a
just a touch different when you put it
out I was kinda hoping for a little bit
of a different design but I think that's
kind of the joke before is that like you
you think it's him and really it's not
it's her but so I was kind of going by
and almost like it zips by bloodline
yeah that's what I feel like they're
related so they they would look like um
but al I like things where I don't know
you put out like oh ring or medalie or
even like the mask you pull it out you
just become something else I don't know
why I like though
I like that setup so anything where it's
like you put the the necklace on it like
consumes you and you turn to this beast
and you're trying to keep control or or
you can't or whatever right
I really like that stuff and I thought
was really cool the way they take it off
throw it on someone else they turn into
a monster they agree the paper pleat
mask was very effective actually
but that said I actually really do like
the demon that Jake pretty cool you look
like a demon no I go really mean demon
you know we're we doing paper plate yo
awesome he's got the two forks yeah so
um yeah it was definitely fun I
definitely liked like so anything with
an idol sphere I'm totally cool with and
yeah now I'm just curious well they're
not they actually stop it they're of a
follow through so how about you you may
speak now oh thank you sir thank you
master
no I actually really liked it um I did
like how it shows how much spin again
cares about his friends and what's going
on around him to the point that he's
willing to put on this you know amulet
that could do who knows how much damage
to him just to save his friend you know
he's like here take her and go yeah I
was kind of curious where because you
know what this thing does you know so
you're sort of like wow how like what is
this gonna do to Finn now and I'm hoping
they carry through I would like to see
some sort of like you know him getting
used to what it did to him or something
but because Marceline and with with
Hudson it makes it they're vampires they
come from this world so it would kind of
make more sense but yeah with the width
in it's like you wouldn't be used to it
I'd like to see if they follow through
I'm not sure if they are yeah um again I
loved the whole stuff reference just
again going back to when the Ice King is
going and the banana and then you go I'm
a banana I nearly lost this I nearly
lost my banana you did that and I waited
all this time just for you to finally
see why I live
you for saying you're a banana oh
definitely worth it you know the one
scene I had to add I almost forgot about
here I don't know why this really struck
a chord with me it's you know the father
obviously betrays Marceline tries to
trick her uh and there's a scene you
know she when she's back to normal and
she says you know daddy you tried to you
tricked me you forced me into taking on
this this business and you turn me into
this monster and everything it just has
this little look like you know come on
it's me
I really wanted to punch him yes you
know and even though it's probably
played a little bit for Laughs its I
guess because I've known people when I
mean jokes are great obviously you know
it's good to make thing something more
like hard if it's called for but there's
times where it's like no you need to be
serious you need to focus and I talked
with people they're just like no not
good I'm not gonna treat what you treat
so seriously seriously I'm just gonna do
it as a joke you know I mean in a moment
where it's like you obviously need to
take something really serious like you
know like something personal or
assignments background all Symonds the
Ice King yes every things I really
didn't take that seriously it's like I
just love the payoff job no I think the
joke is that it was taken so seriously
that's what I don't know that that's
what I got out of it but what I'm
talking about it like I say I mean I'm
not even talking about like adventures
things like you know a father betrayed
his daughter you know and forced her to
do something that she didn't want to do
and it's and like what she's conferring
about he's treating it like a joke and
it's like it's something it's clearly
not a joke you know and I think in a
scene like that like I said just like
wow I just like this guy should be
taking this seriously and he's clearly
not you know and that's something that's
like that's your own kid and you've done
something really despicable and mean
it's just like it's me it's just I come
across people I've done that you've
really important moments and it's just
as frustrating and I think it just
struck a chord with me cuz like I'd like
so for the most part I'm very laid back
and let's make jokes and stuff but there
are times to be serious and you know
during the really obvious times like I
said when someone betrays another family
member
wouldn't you learn a deep dark secret
about someone's past Oh will you hide
not on a TV show I mean like in real
life okay I'm talking about in the
reality they create though that's not
talking about okay look the Ice King the
ice King's past was great I have no
problem with it oh great it wasn't sad
or tragedy comes from how sad and tragic
it is it's incredibly tragic there's not
some great Holocaust Jose migrants know
I know I was saying that I can't like
we're going back to this brought it up
but no team yeah well the flip think go
back it's about right there in the
timeline go go back there I might I
might just any like they'll be this
great big gap but no I I was saying with
that that because they had so much
build-up to it
it was a great payoff but it's also this
great insight into this guy if okay I
don't wanna make that clear
no cuz a lot of people were telling me
like you know no the reason we got angry
is because you were treated like a big
joke and it's like well it's Bob it is a
punch line to this joke but it's also
this great big background on this guy
that's like holy smokes that you've just
discovered more about this world about
this background about this character
about everything that you ever could
before it's incredibly tragic and it's
incredibly sad but it's also coming on
the heels of all this build-up to this
joke and so you have this incredibly sad
depressing thing that's also this
phenomenally funny punch line I just
like giving you crap you don't know you
go job you consistently listen to you
just defend yourself for some reason
those games getting really close to
Hitler they're what you're talking about
was that Seinfeld one and our prices
will go high you've never seen that
episode all I'm saying really I can see
that
there's a lot of people that really hate
that show and I'm not gonna act what I
love but I can see how people I can't
say I hate it I've seen like two or
three episodes and they were fine so I
don't hate it I just never got into it
fair enough so what we've really went
off a lot of stuff of this one I'm sorry
you oh yeah so yeah good episode I hope
it follows through and you will see what
the next one but even if it doesn't it's
still fun and still good adventures
still great designs and yeah I
definitely had a lot fun with it you
forgot about the guy you stand with when
they're standing in line I start trying
to cut them they get a concern he's like
no you go back and keep your coffee
that's my question it's like the Ron say
I guess I get coffee coffee machine in
that line I would just say no I mean
okay I found that hilarious the whole
like you know hit my poking a slick you
back omegle they don't get spanked me is
like sorry man you know the line is like
oh this runs off yeah
it's like vintage a go the back him like
he just runs off I love that honey
generous who I thought a comedy show
could have funny moments surely not by
watching us I mean considering most of
the comedy shows that are out there yeah
this is at least funny except for Parks
and Recreation didn't that like that
it's just the office with a different
cast but it's better honey
did you only see the first episode I
think so I saw the first episode as son
keep watching beyond that it gets better
maybe we'll see okay we're going to talk
more Park and Recreation as well
paper-plate you okay Ron Swanson it's
hilarious
okay he's like really really just give
it an hour James I'd say give on our
chance
what do I get for it another chance know
the show gets another chance Lou I guess
no know by giving the show under a
chance you also get another chance